this is the first time I ever got
exposed to this I got a whatever Batman
hey I'm Emily I'm Stephanie hi I'm Jake
I'm Keeley and I don't know if you guys
know this but kids are absolute lunatics
lunatics and they're adorable
they're hilarious and weird and funny
and we're here to share some of the
darndest things kids have said
one of the the ones that sticks out in
my mind is that a parent at the school
that I was teaching at was worried that
their son wasn't making a lot of friends
and was trying to get you know the
socialization to come through so she
stopped a group of kids on the way out
of school and she knew all of their
names and she said them right out and
she invited them to come over to their
house to watch movies and one kid just
said who are you why do you want to
watch movies with us which honestly is
the smartest thing you can say danger
stranger danger is real but that always
sticks in my head who are you why do you
want to watch movies with me I had this
very sweet introspective little boy he
was very quiet like the kind of kid that
reads on his own he was playing over in
the corner by himself like four hours at
the water table I'm walking by and I
happen to be like picking up some stuff
over in the corner by his table and I'm
thinking in my mind like oh sweet boy
like he's paying so quietly you can hear
him kind of murmuring to himself and
then I just hear a little like my life
and I thought like maybe maybe maybe
there's a chance my life there's a
chance like maybe like oh came out of my
phone or something and he just looks up
he's like well I like so matter of like
he's telling me the weather I started
laughing uncontrollably because I
couldn't keep it together give miss
Emily a minute i snort it a little bit
and then I turned back around and I had
to say like hey I know you're not trying
to be mean but this isn't something we
say at school but his mom came back
later that day she was very cool we had
a really really good laugh cuz I had to
tell her what happened and she just goes
her face she just goes like and she's
like I say they hear everything you say
one time I was
in the bathroom with a couple of kids
one of them had sat on the toilet and
the girl that was with us she looked at
him sitting on the toilet and she goes
wow I like your penis yeah and then he
goes Thanks
it's for peeing yeah and I was like why
did you why did you tell him that why
did you say that and she goes
cuz it's small you know and I died yeah
she said what was on her mind Wow so
already you have coed bathrooms
yeah starting and then kids are talking
yeah Wow it's a learning experience I
feel like when we were younger it didn't
it wasn't like that at all oh yeah like
now like kids are learning each other's
genitals and being like ah yes you have
a penis you use the urinal I do not have
you ever had to share the bathroom with
your students I'd be in another stall oh
boy it's really bad especially when they
know your shoes point out oh yeah yeah
they know they've got all the dirt on
you at that point and trauma that would
be trauma that terrible smell like what
are you doing in here a new thing at our
school was we started like in the last
five years we started for the toys like
the books and the dolls aren't cutting
it anymore for play pretend the girls
want phones they want old phones so they
can be like mommy on the phone so we
started bringing like all of our old
Nokia's and we started bringing those
and let it let him like play with them
and talk to each other so a lot of times
I like will walk in on a conversation
and it's girls playing mommy and they're
all on the phones and they're like
excuse me excuse me I can't come to your
meeting because I actually have book
club and I actually like we're in a
fight right now and we're gonna get a
divorce bye
and I'm like oh okay cleanup time you
know the cleanup song everyone's
cleaning up and all of that in one child
she was not cleaning up and so I was
like um you need to help us clean our
classroom if you're choosing not to open
out to clean up the art space then I
guess it's gonna have to be closed to
you later that really set her off and
she was like wait wait I don't want to
clean up wait and by then it was already
done and I was like sorry it's already
done maybe you can try again tomorrow
and she goes damn it you're damn it
she said you're damn it Wow oh boy
I mean to her it was probably the
sickest burn of all time yeah I've had I
had a sick burn once actually where I
was I was asking one girl very sassy
very much like king of the court playing
with everything I was like can you
please be able to share the toys they
are for everybody and this is the first
time I ever got exposed to this I got a
whatever Batman oh my god yeah
got a bunch of kids sitting on the
carpet and we asked the age-old question
what do you want to be when you grow up
one kids like my mom another kids like a
teacher the other ones like a detective
he's looking I'll call him Danny goes a
banana I just lied and I was like great
kids they have no filter or whatsoever
they will speak their mind almost to a
fault
but you honestly end up getting some
great sound bites to take home and learn
by learn how to control your facial
expression I'll told a lot of times you
can't give what they say power but it's
real hard
[Music]